la primaire démocrate est relancé
joba et d'un en tête et avec une avance
confortable
après un départ au ralenti dans les
états précédent l'ex bras droit de
barack obama est de retour devant ses
partisans
il n'a pas attendu pour se réjouir de sa
première place en caroline du sud où il
a récolté près de 49% des suffrages
il y a quelques jours à peine la presse
et des experts estimé que cette
candidature était morte
maintenant grâce à vous tous le coeur du
parti démocrate
nous venons de remporter une victoire
est une grande victoire grâce à vous
déception en revanche pour celui qui a
connu un démarrage en trombe lors de
cette primaire bernie sanders le
candidat de l'ailé gauche du parti a
récolté seulement 20% des voix mais se
veut optimiste pour la suite et
maintenant nous entrons dans le super
tuesday en virginie et je crois très
fermement que les gens de ce pays pour
le super tuesday et après vont soutenir
notre campagne parce que nous sommes
plus qu'une campagne
nous sommes un mouvement
et c'est dimanche soir que la outsiders
pitbull judge a annoncé son retrait de
la course à l'investiture présidentielle
rappelant que son objectif est de
rassembler les américains face à donald
trump
je prends la décision difficile de
suspendre ma campagne pour la
présidentielle
je ne chercherait plus à être le
candidat démocrate à la présidence pour
2020 mais je ferai tout ce client et
pouvoir pour que nous allions à nouveau
président démocrate en janvier
une annonce surprise qui n'a pas tardé à
faire réagir le président américain
ballet jazz est out
tous ces votes pour le super tuesday
iront à joe biden l'endormi excellent
timing c'est le vrai début de
l'élimination de bernis par les
démocrates
encore une fois pas de nominations
toutefois pas de répit pour les
candidats démocrates toujours en lice
avant le super tuesday qui arrive dès
demain mardi 3 mars
un événement qui constituera forcément
un tournant dans la primaire démocrate
avec 14 et a appelé à se prononcer